-Now that I have everyone's
attention,
I would like to introduce
the 2022 mayor's
youth leadership program
participants.
And in the interest of
inclusion, partici-skirts.
Ines Herrera was a finalist
in the intel space competition.
She speaks Spanish and Mandarin.
Oh, gosh, it doesn't say English
here.
So wel-come, In-es.
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Tina Fey.
That was a clip
from "Mr. Mayor."
-Yes.
-Dream cast.
Ted Danson.
-Yes.
-Holly Hunter. And then
our friend Bobby Moynihan.
-Bobby Moynihan.
-Yeah.
-Vella Lovell and Mike Cabellon.
And they are so, so funny.
Yeah, it's so fun to get to work
with Bobby again
'cause we didn't overlap
all that much, me and Bobby.
-Yeah.
-Or maybe at all.
I don't remember.
-He might have been there right,
like, probably that 2008 year
when you were coming back
for Sarah Palin.
-So much of my late time when I
was there was such a blur,
that I, like --
Sometimes I'm like,
"Mulaney's not Jost, right?"
[ Laughter ]
-A lot of people
have that problem. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But, yeah, and Ted Danson
and Holly Hunter.
And, like, sometimes Ted Danson
will call me, and I still, like,
my phone will say, like, it'll
say "Ted Danson."
And I'm like --
[ Laughs ]
"That's crazy."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
I mean, I would say both Ted
and Holly are the kind of people
that if you came up with any
sort of respect or curiosity
about comedy, they're just two
people that you're just thr--
you can't believe you get to
talk to them.
-Yes. You can't believe you get
to talk to them,
and you spend a lot of energy,
like, making sure
you don't say like,
"I want a toddler, hi."
Like, you can't -- you have to,
like, not do their catch phrases
to them or things
you love about them.
That show, we monitored, because
of the endless pandemic,
they would be filming in
California, and I would monitor
the set from home,
so it would be, like, later.
It'd be like, 7:00 at night
or I'd be cleaning up dinner,
and I'd have a little computer
with a Zoom open.
I could see the set on my TV,
and then the Zoom was
if the actors
wanted to talk to me.
So sometimes, Holly Hunter
would just be like,
"You got anything for me?"
And I'm like, "Oh, God!
Uh, yes. I think -- I think
the one where you're really --"
And I'd just be, like, making --
And she knew I was
making stuff up.
-You also have "Girls5eva."
-Yes.
-This is about
to come out again,
season two on Peacock.
-Yeah, season 2 of "Girls5eva"
comes out -- you can remember it
very easily --
It's May 5th.
It's "Girls5eva" on 5/5.
-Oh, perfect. Oh, look at that.
-Classy.
-Very nicely done.
-Yes, on Peacock.
My friend, Andrea Martin --
you guys know --
-Yeah, of course.
-She wanted to watch
"Girls5eva,"
and so I went to her house
and for like two hours,
I got Peacock on her TV.
And I'm willing to do that
for anybody that needs it.
[ Laughter ]
And then she loved it. Anyway.
So, yeah, that comes out,
starring Paula Pell,
Sara Bareilles, Busy Philipps,
Renee Elise Goldsberry,
guest stars Andrew Rannells,
guest star Amber Ruffin.
-Amber Ruffin, who was just
right here next to me.
-Mm-hmm.
-John Lutz, of both of this show
and "30 Rock" and "SNL" fame.
-Yes, John Lutz and Paula Pell
are reunited,
if you guys were fans of
"The Mapleworth Murders."
-Yeah.
-And you should be.
-Speaking of murders,
you got to be in
"Only Murders in the Building."
-Yes.
-By the way,
"speaking of murders"
was a terrible segue.
-"Speaking of murders,
I'm going to kill you."
-Speaking ever murders, I think
you have something to tell
everybody about
the Bayside Strangler.
-Crickets.
[ Laughter ]
-So, you got to work -- Now,
obviously, over the years,
you've gotten to hang out,
work with Steve Martin
and Martin Short.
But being with them at the same
time just must be --
-Honestly, it's, like, one of
the greatest joys of my life
that I've gotten to meet those
guys and to have a small part on
"Only Murders in the Building,"
a show that my whole family
enjoys and is very invested in.
And it's just --
It is the most joyful set
because those guys love
each other.
-They really do.
-They love each other so much.
It's the happiest set.
Also, it's fun to do a murder
mystery thing because you just
kind of get your pages,
and sometimes you don't know
what's happening, and you don't
have any context
for why your character
is doing that.
And for me, that doesn't change
my acting at all.
-Right.
-So that's like, "Sure!"
-You've never cared about
the backstory of your character.
-No, no.
-You know, it's funny, because
we've obviously done
charity events, the same kind
of events that those guys do.
And the amazing thing about
Marty and Steve is
how seriously they take
being silly.
-Yes.
-And, like, when you see them
backstage before they go on,
they're writing jokes.
They're constantly
tightening the screws.
And how much they care about
the minutia of comedy, I think,
speaks to the longevity of
what they've been doing.
-For sure.
They love, probably, rehearsing
as much as they love
doing stuff.
-And the process of it,
which is really cool.
So, I think we had dinner
the Tuesday
before the final
Christmas "SNL."
-Yes, we went out to dinner.
-Yes.
-Which, by the end of the week,
that seemed insane,
because it was right
when omicron hit.
-Yep. And it was like,
"Ha ha, we're so crazy
for being out to dinner."
-Yeah.
-And then, like, by Wednesday
it was like,
"I can't [bleep]
believe we went out to dinner.
Are we crazy?"
-"We have families!"
-Yeah. But then -- And then
the crazy thing was you --
So, Paul Rudd hosted
the Christmas episode of "SNL."
And you showed up,
and that was crazy.
-It was crazy.
That whole week was crazy.
I think that week,
Thursday night, I went to do --
I was a guest at the show
"Freestyle Love Supreme"
on Broadway.
Did anyone get to see that?
[ Cheers ]
It was very cool.
So it was
a fully improvised rap.
It's Lin-Manuel Miranda's show,
and it's a fully improvised
rap musical.
And they were like, "Will you
come and be a special guest?"
And I used to be
a professional improviser.
-Famously.
-I was in a union for it.
-Right.
-And I was like,
"I would love to."
As it got closer, I started
to panic more and more.
I was like, "They know that I
don't -- I don't improvise,
like, raps at all, right?"
I kept checking,
e-mailing people like,
"But not music,
just like a story?"
And they were like, "You're
going to have a great time."
And I just -- As it got closer,
I got more and more nervous.
The day of, I e-mailed with
the stage manager.
I was like, "But not -- They
know I can't do music, right?"
They were like,
"Sure, for sure."
I got there,
and then also, like,
everyone in the city had COVID.
I was like, "Why am I in
a theater? This is nuts."
Lin-Manuel Miranda was
in the show that night,
I think because everyone else
had COVID.
I'm not sure.
[ Laughter ]
So I go with them,
and they're rehearsing me,
and they were like, "Do you want
to play this game and this game?
You would just have to,
like, sing the hook."
And I was like, "I do not --"
Also I had looked up --
I was like, "Who are the other
people who have been guests?"
I looked it up, and it was like,
oh, Wayne Brady.
That's not good.
It was like, Jimmy [bleep]!
Jimmy did this?
So I was like,
"Nope, I can't sing the hook.
I'll tell a story." And they
were really nice about it.
And then seemed fine.
Then we go to warm up
before the show.
And they said, "We're gonna do,
like, an improv warm-up,
if you want to come down."
So I go the basement.
We're doing, like, regular
improv warm-ups.
I'm like,
"Okay, we're in a circle."
And then they start doing
their rap warm-up,
which is they take words
out of a bucket
and they freestyle rap,
and it's amazing.
And they pass it to each other,
and every single person
is amazing.
And I'm in this circle.
And I'm sweating from,
like, my spine out.
And then they get to the person
next to me,
and then I just,
like, lean back.
And then that person just gives
it back to Lin-Manuel
who, you know, does another one,
and then, like,
tries to throw it to me.
And I looked at
Lin-Manuel Miranda,
and I went,
"No, I don't do that!"
And then I threw myself
on the ground.
[ Laughter ]
And I was like,
"If anyone has taken improv,
the only thing you're not
supposed to do is yell 'no.'"
[ Laughter ]
And I told Amy that story.
She was like,
"Why didn't you just go like,
joop-de-beep-de-beep?"
I was like, "I -- I panicked!"
[ Laughter ]
But I just told a story,
and it was fine.
-Alright, good.
-That's part one of the weekend.
-Yeah.
-So then that's Thursday.
I wake up Friday convinced
I have COVID. Right?
I was with a full theater
of people.
I'm supposed to shoot at
"Only Murders,"
but they test you all the time.
I'm like,
"Okay, my test is good."
I go to
"Only Murders in the Building."
I'm supposed to shoot with Marty
and Steve and then Selena Gomez.
So I'm rehearsing with Marty.
You have your masks on.
And they go -- And I'm like,
"Okay." [ Clears throat ]
And then they go to put
the microphone on you,
and then you're going to
take your mask off
and they're gonna shoot,
and I was like,
"Oh, my thr--
My throat hurts a little bit."
And I thought, you know,
I don't want to...
-Yeah.
-I'm not taking Marty and Steve
and Selena down, no way.
So I pulled someone aside like,
"Can I have another rapid test?"
And they're like,
"You know, we're just gonna, um,
see what Disney says."
And apparently what Disney says
was, "Get out of here."
[ Laughter ]
So they sent me home.
I should also -- Shoot, I messed
up the beginning of the story,
is that I already knew on
Tuesday that I was supposed to
go to "SNL" on Saturday.
-Yeah.
-Because they needed someone
to do "Update" because...
-Oh, right.
-...Jost was out.
-Jost had COVID.
-Right.
We can say that now, I guess.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And so I was like, "Okay."
So then they kick me out of
"Only Murders."
I go home and I'm like --
[ Clears throat ]
They give me another test.
Still good.
I'm like, "Alright.
I'm going to do 'Update.'"
I go to "SNL."
It's a ghost town.
[ Laughter ]
Everyone's there. Rudd is there.
People are dropping like flies,
getting pulled, going home.
And then somehow, that weird
show, it was just, like,
me and Rudd and Kenan
and Che and Tom Hanks.
Like, somehow, me and Tom Hanks
are the expendables.
[ Laughter ]
It was like, "No one cares
if these two die."
And Tom Hanks is like,
"I had it. I had it first."
-He had it first, yeah.
-Yeah.
"I'm good."
-That was the thing.
If you were willing to get it
first, you'd be immune forever.
-That's not, no, that's not --
-That's the deal.
That's the deal he made, yeah.
-Okay.
And then it was fine
and I never got COVID.
So probably tonight.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, thank you so much
for being here.
It's always a pleasure.
-That was so long.
[ Laughter ]
-Tina Fey, everybody.
"Mr. Mayor," Tuesday nights
at 8:30 here on NBC.
And the second season of
"Girls5eva" premieres May 5th,
5/5 on Peacock.